je réponds bien volontiers à la question
que vous posez qui est une question qui
est au fond au coeur du pacte
républicain
comment dans une société démocratique et
libre peut-on faire prévaloir l'ordre
public
comment dans une société démocratique
libre construit sur l'idée
d'universalité de l'universalité de
l'homme des femmes et des hommes
c'est-à-dire leur profonde égalité leur
profonde endroit lent profond de liberté
comment faire que cette part pour le
moins obscures et j'allais dire presque
éternel d'incompréhensions de peurs de
stigmatisation de ce qui est différent
de ce qui n'est pas identique
comment faire pour la contenir et dans
toute la mesure du possible pour la
faire disparaître
c'est pas une question simple madame la
présidente
et si si nous vivions dans un monde
idéal et qu'il suffisait de proscrire
d'interdire le racisme nous l'aurions
déjà fait et l'effet est déjà produite
par dans le loiret déjà produit ses
effets ça n'est pas le cas et donc la
question que vous posez et sensible j'ai
un désaccord avec vous je ne sais pas si
j'ai un désaccord avec vous madame la
présidente
mais en tout cas je ne crois pas et je
ne laisserai pas dire car ça ne
correspond pas l'expérience que j'ai que
la police ou la gendarmerie serait et
c'est d'ailleurs parce que vous avez dit
madame la présidente
ce n'est pas ce que vous avez dit je le
dis parce que n'est pas impossible que
ma réponse dépasse les murs de cette
enceinte
ce n'est pas ce que vous avez dit je ne
peux pas laisser dire et je ne laisserai
jamais dire que la police ou la
gendarmerie serait d organisation des
institutions violentes ou raciste elles
ne sont je le dis madame la présidente
ni l'une ni l'autre
ni l'une ni l'autre la police et la
gendarmerie sont des institutions qui à
la différence de beaucoup d'autres sont
extrêmement contrôlée placé sous l'oeil
vigilant des médias de nos concitoyens
des organismes internes d'inspection et
de contrôle la police et la gendarmerie
ou plus exactement les policiers et les
gendarmes exerce des missions
redoutablement difficile vous le savez
vous le savez rester calme en toutes
circonstances appréhender les
malfaiteurs être exposés à un risque
permanent du simple fait que l'on est
dépositaire de l'autorité publique bien
souvent du simple fait que l'on porte un
uniforme et nous avons tous tous en tête
des exemples nombreux de femmes et
d'hommes quels qu'ils soient qui ont été
attaqué et pris pour cible parce qu'ils
portaient des uniformes qui fait leur
fierté et qui est notre protection
vous avez évoqué cette période
particulière et au fond malheureuse dit
des gilet jaune et vous avez indiqué
madame la présidente que cette période
démontrerait à l'évidence des
prétendants démontrerait des violences
ou illustrerait par donc voilà vous avez
raison illustrerait des violences
policières
cette période a été violente elle n'a
pas été le fait de violences choisi
exercée par la police sur des
manifestants pacifiques
je vous le dis comme je le pense comme
je les ai vécus madame la présidente
nous avons assisté dans cette période je
ne vais pas tout le monde dans le même
panier bien entendu mais nous avons
assisté dans cette période à des mises
en cause à des insultes et des crachats
à des violences incroyablement intense à
l'égard des policiers et des gendarmes
l'exercice du métier de policier de
gendarme dans la société dans laquelle
nous vivons et nous pouvons regretter
que la société dans laquelle nous vivons
soit brutale et violente est difficile
et je veux dire madame la présidente la
confiance l'estiment le respect absolu
absolue que j'ai pour les femmes et les
hommes qui s'engagent pour protéger
leurs concitoyens
et c'est parce que j'ai cette estime
cette confiance ce respect que j'ai
cette exigence que vous partagez j'en
suis sûr et cette exigence d'exemplarité
qui dit qu'aucun acte raciste ne peut
être tolérée dans l'absolu est peut-être
encore moins lorsqu'il est le fait de
quelqu'un qui est dépositaire de
l'autorité publique
cette exigence doit être mise en oeuvre
je ne veux pas je ne veux pas que le
débat intense et délicat de la formation
de l'explication des missions de la
police de la définition des techniques
les plus adaptées dans une société qui
devient de plus en plus violente
je ne veux pas que ce débat soit comme
confisqué par des prises de positions
théâtrale par des raccourcis ou des
amalgames que tous nous avons dénoncé et
que nous devons tous continuer à
dénoncer avec des situations qui se
déroulerait ailleurs je le dis comme je
le pense
nous devons être confiants nous devions
être respectueux nous devons être
exigeants vis-à-vis des femmes et des
hommes qui font vivre la police
nationale et la gendarmerie
et c'est cette ligne qui est une ligne
d'équilibré qui est une ligne
d'équilibré que je veux tenir mais je ne
veux pas madame la présidente que la
peur change de camp
je ne veux pas que la présomption passe
de celui qui troublent l'ordre public à
celui qui le défend parce que si nous
acceptons cette facilité de l'esprit
sous le coup de l'émotion et l'émotion
est légitime et à les grandes et à les
partager
mais si nous acceptons cette facilité
alors c'est un basculement de la
république qui intervient et je vais
vous dire mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le basculement de la
république quand je vois cela je me dis
qu'il n'est pas si loin alors je vous
propose madame la présidente d'être
ensemble exigeante avec les femmes et
les hommes qui composent la police
nationale gendarmerie
et de ce point de vue là nous sommes
d'accord mais que nous leur disions
parce que ici au sénat on est aussi une
institution parce que le premier
ministre
il est chef du gouvernement que nous
leur disions aussi vigoureusement au
delà de cette exigence notre confiance
et notre respect